this week on quadriga Ukraine escalation
right or might the tension in eastern
Ukraine is getting worse by the day this
week saw the first deaths during clashes
between pro-russian commandos and
soldiers of the Kiev controlled army
Ukraine's acting president alexander
turchinov has described the fighters as
terrorists and said others would be put
on trial the latest meeting of Russia
Ukraine the US and the EU produced an
agreement to de-escalate the crisis and
disarm pro-russian groups meanwhile
russia's President Vladimir Putin has
been talking about the importance of
dialogue he denies Russian troops are in
Ukraine but has not ruled out sending
them is more fighting inevitable in
eastern Ukraine does the appeal to
international law have any relevance in
this struggle your host this week
Melinda crane hello and welcome to quad
Riga where is the situation in Ukraine
heading is a diplomatic or political
solution feasible and if so what might
it look like those are some of the
questions we want to pose two three
journalists who've been following
developments in Ukraine very closely and
I'm very pleased to welcome arena solo
nenko she's a Ukrainian political
scientist that the European University V
Audrina here in Germany previously she
worked with George Soros open society
foundations and the east-west Institute
in Ukraine and it's a pleasure to have
with us even Rajon off he is
editor-in-chief of the Russian news
agency roughly which is part of the
Russian state funded broadcaster Russia
today he previously worked as deputy
editor-in-chief at another Russian state
broadcaster rossiya-24 and it's a
pleasure to welcome anton toyin offski
he's an American journalist of Russian
origin as correspondent for The Wall
Street Journal based here in Berlin he
recently covered the Crimea referendum
and the Sochi Olympics he previously
reported from Moscow for the washington
post and the AP news age
see I'd like to start out by getting the
assessment from all three of you about
whether you think Ukraine might be
heading as Russia warned it could toward
civil war arena sonechko well the
situation is very tense now I don't see
really preconditions for the Civil War
according to last opinion polls in
eastern regions of Ukraine up to twenty
percent might want to join Russia but
the rest are polluted pro-ukrainian we
don't see my super Ukrainian
demonstrations in eastern Ukraine people
are afraid they are less space they're
more passive than people in Kiev or
western Ukraine but I don't see any
preconditions for civil war without
external interference and this external
appearance brings up tensions and this
might lead to some yeah sort of fighting
I hope no civil work shall we even
without your guardian of what is here
well this presumed Russian interference
Russian Russian meddling in and eastern
Ukraine is appears more and more like
Saddam Hussein's chemical labs
dot-to-dot zero pardon everybody talks
about presumed Russian aggression but
nobody's seen any Russian troops there
and how could they get into Ukraine
there is a border and if the Russian
journalists from who are trying to go to
Ukraine to report from they're getting a
denied entrance to the country because
well from for no reason sometimes or on
really lovable reasons like they do not
have enough funds to sustain themselves
in Ukraine during two or three weeks
let's say let's say it's not Russian
troops but possibly Russian agent
provocateur agents trying to stir up
trouble and something that puzzled me
today Vladimir Putin said in a call-in
show in Moscow we don't have anybody in
eastern Ukraine but the fact is he said
the same thing about Crimea when it was
going on and now today for the first
time he admitted Russia did have agents
in Crimea why should we version this
time around Russia did did have like
16,000 agents in Crimea that's actually
the military person
out that was according to the treaty
between Russia and you crave stationed
deployed there in Sevastopol and small
wonder that the soldiers didn't stay in
the barracks while the country was
sinking into chaos and Civil War but
that's that's a different issue if we
speak of eastern Ukraine if again if you
imply and assume those are Russian
agents but don't produce any evidence it
really looks puzzling to me and why
wouldn't we assume that those same on
people are Ukrainian citizens and
officers or employees of the Ukrainian
police and army which abandons that key
of government massively as you see now
with with this attempted crackdown in
all those Eastern Ukrainian cities which
failed that the Army is changing sides
the police is changing sides so my son
hello just a minute it's Ukrainian
citizens Ukrainian army or police
officers taking the buildings the way it
happened before in Kiev okay let's come
back to that point shortly Anton toy
enough the question of whether there are
Russian agents in some way helping to
foment separatist sentiment intelligence
services apparently have said in the
West they do believe Russia is playing a
role in doing so what do you think who
should we believe it's I mean it's if
you listen to different even different
governments in the West the assessments
are different obviously the US has been
very direct in saying they believe the
unrest in eastern Ukraine has been
fomented by the Russians here in Germany
they've been a little softer and said
you know they suspect that this was
going on in a you know key of itself the
current government there has said a
Russian said there's Russian involvement
in the unrest but there hasn't been hard
proof I think I think that's true but I
think to your question on on the Civil
War it's it comes down to what what do
people who have lived in the same
country peacefully for
decades is there really enough kind of
pent-up tension or pent-up hatred for
that matter to bring civil war I I hope
not i think the world hopes not but but
we've been unfortunately we've been
surprised quite a bit in the last few
months why dad I'm sorry that right
sector and miri are sending his
paramilitaries to slow dance in
kramatorsk as he sees that the Army in
his view fails to crack down on those
protesters why then if you if you say
there is no sentiment actually right
nectar is a small group of radicals
there may be 300 people they are
announcing run presidential elections he
has less than one percent support let's
not all steamy play for ministers in the
cabinet that's for Buddha party that's a
difference it's a party which has seats
in the parliament this is the case in
any country if you have seats in the
parliament you become part of the
cabinet I'm sorry if I do not diss earn
eight correctly between various fascist
parties in Ukraine but we're all safe
fool around sooo cold and fascist that's
one thing and I Buddha actually was born
under the name National Socialist Party
of Ukraine last time he would mention
Samson and which was introduced it was
2004 and afterwards he was expelled from
the audio crane party it's another party
which was headed by former president
viktor yushchenko since then he didn't
mention anything like that and i have to
say that he's his support is also one
percent Hebrew around presidential
elections as well so well it's not
always team a they play a minor role a
small group of radicals and radical
rights how much more support in European
culture represented in the government
running Varian elections and the yo big
party rastrick oracle Melilla pen a
marine lepen party in hungary we'll see
what kind of outcome of elections for
the european parliament so a radical
right parties have much more support in
in Western Europe and is not a problem
why the raises problem in Ukraine where
they have much less support i mean i
think i think that the this talk of
who's fascist and who isn't mrs. some of
the some of the point which is that that
even in Crimea where there was truly a
lot of support for breaking away from
Ukraine and
joining Russia I mean some of it was you
know some of it was was patriotism but
you could also tell there were just
people who were disillusioned with the
politics of Kiev who you know felt that
there hadn't been enough investment in
Crimea and who just thought they could
live better economically in Russia so I
think it you know it and you make we may
well be seeing some of that in eastern
Ukraine right now but I think I don't
think we need to boil all of this down
to ethnic divisions or whose fascist and
who isn't there are you know it's in
there other I think it's giving this
little [ __ ] let me ask you this you
know you say Russia appears to be
playing a role in fomenting
dissatisfaction and and separatist
sentiment but do you really believe that
Putin has a clear strategy of doing so
and has a real playbook for dismembering
Ukraine yes absolutely i mean long long
time ago lignum rozinsky told that was
out Ukraine Russia ceases to be an
empire what I see now is a very sort of
imperialistic sentiments in Russia will
have eighty percent of support for Putin
and this policy is aimed at
destabilizing Ukraine putting already
told today that he will not recognize he
kind of hinted that he will not
recognize presidential elections he's
talking about federalism which would
disintegrate the country if Ukraine
succeeds as a democratic prosperous
country it will be a threat for Putin's
regime and he understand that so you of
course the strategy ask you why would
you disturb lies a neighbor on in which
economy you have like billions of
billions of vested interest by the
Russian business I mean who destabilizes
a country just next door to you what
sense does it make do you have any
answers Russian business invested
billions in the Ukrainian infrastructure
metal industry steelworks mobile IT
communications everything food beverage
industry whatever it's some industrial
branches are two forty percent owned by
the Russian companies isn't it insane to
destabilize a country of course now with
that government in Kiev saying that they
are going to default on all Russian
debts and not paying anything back and
they are going to nationalize that
assets belonging to the Russian
companies and the Russian individuals it
certainly gives some reason for concern
within Russia but do you have any any
any reasonable points22 to actually
prove that a country would destabilize
another country right next door
provoking maybe floods of refugees
provoking havoc on your border which
triggers which feels skills over
inevitably to your own home grounds that
argument being made by mr. watt Janowski
is premise on the idea that Vladimir
Putin would act rationally in economic
terms but if we see what his actions
have been so far i wonder if we
sometimes don't operate under the wrong
assumptions about what rationality would
mean in this situation meaning russia is
clearly already losing money not only
due to sanctions but also due to
declining trust on the part of russians
who are parking their money elsewhere
seventy billion already flowed out of
Russia just in this court economic
quarter are we perhaps assuming too much
rationality on the part of President
Putin I mean we don't even necessarily
need to try to get into his head and
figure out what he isn't isn't thinking
but in terms of because in terms of the
the consequences of what's going on
certainly there are disadvantages too
there would be disadvantages to Russia
to having a civil war in one of the one
of its largest neighbors but I think
it's also worth looking at what's going
on inside Russia and the political
situation inside Russia we have seen I
think without a doubt that that what's
gone on in the last couple of months has
strengthened Vladimir Putin politically
at home at a time when economists have
been concerned about the direction of
the Russian economy and this has what
has happened in the last few months has
provided a pretext for clamping down
further and independent
yeah in Russia so I think it's also you
know it's also worth looking at not just
what are what's in Russia's interests
outside its borders but also what does
all this mean for Putin and that's a
very short-term consideration though
isn't it even bojinov it may be helping
to shore up support for Vladimir Putin
right now but should the economy get
much much worse in coming years will
that not lead to popular sentiment
turning against I think it's actually
the the whole sort of structure seems a
bit head over heels of vice versa to
make his Putin you portray him as
someone who just reached out and grabbed
Crimea out of the clear blue sky was not
the case first Crimea was split by that
coup d'etat in Kiev with people
extremely worried of yet another
oligarchs sent by Kieff coming now to
rule them like kolomoisky rota rota who
are also refused by the people in
Donetsk or respectively Harkov and with
the the Russian base and the
geographical situation and the ethnic
the population structure of Crimea that
developed it this situation escalated
and ended up in that referendum which
led to the Secession of Crimea from
Ukraine and then Putin well call it
using the benefit of the moment approved
the integration of Crimean to Russia so
it was not action it was reaction to the
chain of events that started not in
Moscow and maybe not in Keith let me ask
you this Vladimir Putin said today in
this call-in program that he is not
ruling out the possibility that he will
also move move into eastern Ukraine he
said he hopes he doesn't have to do it
but he has the authority to do so do you
think he'll use that I think it's it's a
it's a misinterpretation of his words he
never said that he's going to move with
the troops into eastern Ukraine but if
and as we see I'm afraid I would wiling
it out I would really want
that the that you were right and there
is no danger no threat of civil war in
Ukraine but seeing tax and heavy
artillery deployed against the room
against your own citizens its kind of
reason to worry that there is still some
threat and still some danger and if that
happens then it is really totally
unpredictable it's a non predict the
unpredictable situation if it should be
a war in those parts of the Queen we're
now that government in Kiev tries to
crack down on the protest movement using
force but fortunately I have to say
those forces deny them allegiance and
change sides and abandon those who sent
them to Dan yet scan and Commodores can
slavyansk but if at some point some of
those forces don't and they start
shooting at the people there then I
think it might have consequences that
Vladimir Putin meant saying that quote
that you just mentioned it in a saloon a
coat does that explain why Kiev moved so
slowly to quell the separatism this week
it had given an ultimatum it said that
it would act by Monday it did not do so
some people said it did too little too
late does he have actually have this
situation under control at all well
there are many people are dissatisfied
with what how the government is wrecked
and many people in Ukraine want to see
more active action so but the
explanation is that the government wants
to avoid any bloodshed and of course if
but [ __ ] happens it will be pretext for
Putin to bring up to bring troops to
Ukraine so of course they try to be
careful what we see groups of armed men
in common plush trying to occupy public
buildings TV stations in airport today
was in Donetsk was occupied of course I
mean in any normal country you would try
to prevent this or fight with this kind
of people yes that importantly three of
them died of these people who tried to
do these actions today because they were
shooting they will want to stop but they
didn't comply so
of course I mean so I have to stop this
somehow bad time I'm sorry storming and
occupying public buildings is it
something unique for the eastern Ukraine
did may experience a lot of storming and
occupying with public buildings and kill
without our people who come up without
arms and those people were armed and the
28 policemen were killed and quite a lot
of protesters were shot in the back and
where's by the way did that
investigation produce any results that
the new government is actually should be
pursuing very actively to find out from
how public buildings occupied invest in
Ukraine during the yellow Maidan
revolution and what is happening now I
think we will see a clear difference
what kind of people are storming a
little behind these buildings and there
is there are some videos on YouTube
there are some conversations which were
allegedly leaked at an old conversations
which were we show that these are
Russian military men or special forces
which operate in Ukraine I don't have
any legal Besler that in post and
Ukrainian government told that they will
present the evidence in Geneva so let's
let's hope they will present some
evidence and I don't know enough we have
again two very different claims being
made here Kia says look we have got to
take action we have a separatist
uprising going on Moscow is saying this
is unconstitutional this is a grave
crime how do you see it is it truly a
crime for a government to try to put
down an uprising within its own borders
I mean the this is all it this is all
such a difficult situation I think it
really is really hard to assess I mean
and you see it every day and how hard it
is for the West to respond and to
describe what's going on because because
as you say there are such different
analyses of what's going on and the
people and and and when you bend what
you know when you go to Crimea or these
places you you you realize that so much
of what's happening on the ground is
being driven by help you
will perceive you know the events and so
there are truly people many people in
eastern Ukraine who view what happened
as a coup d'etat who do feel threatened
there are at the same time you know that
these sort of other things going on that
we hear about it's it's it's it's it's a
very hard thing I think for anyone to to
really wrap their minds around here in
southern ankle what is the role of the
media in that in shaping exactly those
kind of perceptions we know that more
and more people in eastern Russia are
now in eastern Ukraine are now seeing
State Russian media is that part of what
is fomenting this sentiment well
actually Russian TV was kind of
prohibited in Ukraine but still some
people in its new crane they can still
watch it but I mean as I told the public
opinion polls which were conducted not
so long ago with just three some weeks
ago show that maximum twenty percent of
people innocent Ukraine would like to
join Russia this is a lot of people
across which disappointed to commit his
economic situation with ya the the
government in Ukraine would have a
caller has dog has not done enough for
the people and now there was a chance
maybe to do some reforms there is a
chance but in the situation I think one
interesting thing on the role of the
media is even if we look right here in
Berlin there's obviously a large
russian-speaking community here and many
Russian émigré is here get their news
from Russian TV and it's it's
interesting talking to people who get
their new you know two Russians here who
get their news from Western media people
who get their news from Russian media
even there even you know even here in
Berlin we have people with completely
different evaluations of what's going
what I have to agree with the arena on
is that speaking both of media and of
the point you just made the language of
the media how those who are protesting
against the government in Kiev are
labeled pro-russian separatists which is
a totally full language because as you
rightly say maybe 20
% of them I don't know how accurate the
survey's by just give it the benefit of
the doubt advocate integration into
Russia while the rest is dis protesting
against that this government that did
not recognize that they not feel
represented by Davis let's look how we
have it in them we have seven
journalists veritable journalists
operating now for roughly in Ukraine six
of them in eastern Ukraine one in Kiev
and they send us like each three to five
video stories a day showing people who
took to the streets in Kharkov
chromodoris slavyansk and what oh so you
see what other places best in with your
model who show their passports and say
we are Ukrainians we are we are local
citizens we don't have any Russian
troops here or any Russian are Jones
provocateur we just are we just are
scared of and feel threatened as you say
by that government we also see how
actually the the industry and our life
standard is scrambling here and we want
to protest against it we want to call
the shots instead of having those
oligarchs sent from Kiev ruling us even
watch enough let me ask you whether you
would agree with the German government
which this week said that Russian state
television is inflaming the tensions in
eastern Ukraine and called on it to tone
down its reporting do you take on that
criticism would you say yes roughly
Russia today they have been perhaps
providing media reporting that makes the
tensions worse rather than better no
absolutely not well you should make
really a picture for yourself go to
Russia today watch the coverage here's
an older property was on yesterday and
liev wants to spark war between NATO and
Russia that's a headline on Russia today
from yesterday Wednesday of this week is
that not an inflammatory have no it's
not inflammatory it's a it maybe opinion
driven but it's not inflammatory and
it's absolutely well we'll go to the fox
news web page
mean it'sit's you're not gonna get an
argument for me they are very
inflammatory or even to MSNBC or those
liberal media I'm actually accusing rush
of annexation of Crimea which is again
totally inaccurate in terms I don't
think that they that headline that you
just picked out of Artie's very
comprehensive coverage of what's going
on in Ukraine is first inflammatory or
representative the whole coverage and
please go to the website of our agency
and just watch those stories underrated
uncommented raw video with the net sound
with the sound bites of the people whom
our journalists none of them Russian by
the way film there on the ground in
eastern Ukraine okay let me ask you
Anton troyanovsky that headline Kiev
fomenting conflict between NATO and
Russia is there any real risk of a
larger armed conflict in the region as a
whole between the North Atlantic Treaty
Organization and Russia is that really a
possibility here and could it occur if
not by intent perhaps by accident and no
one wants that I think Putin has said
Russia doesn't want that Obama has said
the US doesn't want that certainly
Angela Merkel at the very beginning of
the stuff happening in Crimea said very
clearly acting militarily is not an
option for us obviously also the members
of NATO have said they'll come you know
they'll honor their agreements to to to
defend any attack on the on NATO's
borders and people in the Baltic States
in particular have been worried about
that happening but I think at this point
that's there even even if there is no
military confrontation between NATO and
Russia there's many other ways in which
this situation could get worse that that
we should really be worried about Irina
solo nenko there are some in the US John
McCain the senior u.s. Republican
senator for example he would like to see
the US provides some arms to Kiev to the
government would that be a good idea
we've seen certainly that the
armed forces in Ukraine are
under-equipped and definitely have some
control issues as well well it would be
too sensitive if NATO us interferes but
for instance let's look at the European
Union it has common security policy for
the past 20 years you had 22 police
operations police and peacekeeping
operations all over the road including
in Europe in Kosovo I think it would be
a more reasonable way to help maybe to
stabilize situation you to crane and
Ukraine to send some of the a
peacekeeping or police mission from the
EU for instance just to observe maybe to
make sure there are no tensions it's
calm and so on it would be a more
reasonable way and I think you has other
leverages economic sanctions Russia is
very dependent on selling gas to the
European Union on trade and I think you
will not suffer as much if it can
introduces economic sanctions whereas
putting perhaps makes a second thought
about what he's doing the US did
announce that that they will send
non-lethal aid to to to Ukraine
including I think helmets but they're
also promising money as is the EU but
are they doing enough and won't that
money flow right into the coffers of
Gazprom money to Ukraine I mean there
are it certainly especially if you talk
to officials here in in Berlin but I
think also all over Europe there is
concern about corruption going on in in
Ukraine and continuing at you know
that's not going to stop overnight with
any new with any new government not only
corruption they've got a big open bill
with Gazprom they Oh gasps from a lot of
money yes and if you look at it's been
interesting to watch your gas / I'm
actually here in Germany they've been
working very hard to convince the German
public that they have nothing to fear
about gas from shutting off gas
deliveries to Europe whatever happens
let's talk about what kind of diplomatic
and political solutions might be out
there the meeting in Geneva did say that
all the parties will continue to talk
they do plan to have future meetings
with one another
is that a success in itself even large
enough that people are finally sitting
down and actually meeting face-to-face
that had not happened of course until
now Sergey Lavrov and the Ukraine
Foreign Minister were at one point in
the same building but did not meet is
this a progress assigned a progress in
itself as you know Russia does not
recognize that government in Kiev so I
don't see actually much chance for love
love to talk directly to another
appointed Foreign Minister of Ukraine
but in this tense situation of course
the mere fact of the talks is something
encouraging although I have to agree
with the Russian position that for those
talks to succeed the representatives of
the protest movement in the eastern part
of Ukraine should be involved and the
leaders of this movement who are who
were abducted and jailed in Kiev should
be released and obviously so that the
all sides of the conflict are
represented because this movement in
eastern Ukraine is now also a factor if
you want it or not it's not Russia it's
about the people of Ukraine and not
aligning standing against their
government the way they stood in Kiev
against the unicorns government now it's
vice versa it's a turn page situation
same occupation of public buildings but
why they were enthusiastically applauded
in December and January now it is called
pro-russian separatists again using this
term to label those people who are just
opposing the government the first lady
translating a Russian position official
position is very interesting because mr.
Lavrov several days ago said the
treasure would accept taking part in
negotiations in Geneva only on the
condition is representative from eastern
Ukraine is present and he actually named
a name and mr. Dobkin who was a quiz
active in hard kid and he is known also
for supplying this sucks to give Ramadan
to beat protesters and come on if you if
you name somebody from outside and
saying this is a representative of
separatists or not
when people who are who fight for
whatever in eastern Ukraine it should be
in Geneva what kind of position is that
the u.s. government represented by
Victoria Nuland said we want here at
sanook to head the Ukrainian government
and now yet sanuk is at the helm does it
give you any any words any concern you
can say it officially if I mean let's
give out a further point of the Geneva
talks they also agreed that they will
work together to try to disarm and
disband irregular military groups how
much difference does that make you think
you're in a salon a CO and how effective
can it be some of these groups actually
were not particularly heavily armed
anyway and some of the arms they're
using they've taken away from your
country's own military yeah there's a
question who is going to disarm the
Ukrainian police Ukrainian military
which is taking part in an
anti-terrorist operation as how it's
called is trying to disarm in them but
it's quite difficult so will Russia
disarm people whom it sent that would be
very important but I don't know
otherwise who else is going to disarm
them so that's okay they agreed but so
what so what and another problem I see
in those talks engineer is that with the
US you actually never know who calls the
shots as a Obama administration or is it
neocons is it military industrial
complex or is it that huge intelligence
community that seems to be completely
gotten out of hand and spies on world
leaders without their own president
snowing so that's that's a problem also
also for Russia and for all involved in
those talks that with the US you
actually you now know who who is the
actually where's the decision making
sort of nerve center in the particular
situation regarding Ukraine I mean I
think that's certainly the conservative
establishment in the US would have
wanted Obama to act a lot more
aggressively in the situation without
military force right from the beginning
they don't want any boots on the ground
so there's a real difference what what
would they really have done differently
no that's what I'm saying is is that the
concern
establishment didn't want him to rule
out military force did want him to want
the US government to provide military
aid to Ukraine so I think just in terms
of this from the beginning they said we
will never send forces into Ukraine and
certainly that was the words of McCain
and of every other neocon as well so I
don't see the real and and we'd see what
the US is doing and they are not
delivering even weapons at the moment
right exactly so I'm saying that that
this this shows I think that that it's
not the neo-cons standing behind obama
here and calling the shots obama has
been a lot more you know focused on
calling for talks in conferred for
de-escalation then and he's gotten a ton
of criticism back home from the
republicans and from conservative common
let me ask you whether you think that
continuing talks they said they will
continue to meet in different formats
will that be effective do you think in
defusing this situation along with
measures to disarm those irregular
irregular malicious I mean I it does
seem to be the most the most promising
course of action at you know I I don't
know what else obviously the question is
how you talk and and in what you know
what sort of trust the various parties
have in one another right now there does
not seem to be much trust among the
parties and that's a real that's a real
problem but it seems like that's what
you have to do Sarah Sorak without any
practical implications right I'm sorry
it might have been just a rhetoric
without practical implications they told
ok we're going to disarm it and what my
question is also even version of whether
at this point the genie is out of the
bottle as we say the separatists impulse
clearly has taken fire in the east do
you really think that political measures
diplomatic measures from above can get
it back under control certainly not it
is a factor well external influence is a
factor but not the crucial factor that
the decision is with the people in
Ukraine of course and it's beyond any
doubt beyond any question
it's about forming and establishing a
government that all the people who live
in Ukraine feel themselves represented
by and they're not scared by that is
going to happen on May twenty-fifth
elections are scheduled well Russia has
said it may or may not recognize the
results of those elections the problem
is that now we have at least judging by
the Ukrainian Constitution a government
which is not covered by the Constitution
a government which by the way is the
first step when they came to power in
the night of februari 20 20 second after
banning the Russian language has the
second official language Oh today they
by day this yes after an angry call from
but also from Brussels veto okay let's
look to the future because we don't have
that majority I'm in our program
elections on May twenty-fifth does that
promise yeah improve that so this cost
the shadow on the future of course if
you have a government that violates the
Constitution you are the you either send
the government to jail or you you change
or abolish the Constitution I mean it's
irreconcilable the paradox that now
exists in Ukraine okay but six weeks
until May twenty-fifth a little longer
that could change that situation ering
the Salonika what do you expect from
those elections can they help to put the
country back on a stable and unified
course and do they need to be
accompanied by a referendum on a federal
structure this is one compromise
proposal that has been made including by
mr. torch in off is that a possibility
would that help but to have elections is
very important it will bring legitimate
president to power the president has
many less functions now than before due
to the change of the constitution so
it's much more important thing to have
early parliamentary elections and in
which would ensure that you will bring
new parties into the parliament the last
are a small young parties which grew out
of civil society is very important to
give them a possibility to run elections
I would like to mention that in the past
weeks actually the government the
Parliament adopted quite a few important
laws like today the law on creation of
the public
broadcasting was voted the plan was to
do this after the Orange Revolution but
they failed and now finally it's going
to happen it's very important to have
impartial state-funded TV but will be
independent apart from that there was a
law on public procurement which reduces
corruption substantially or risks of
corruption there was a law on judiciary
which according to which judges who were
in just fully rue who ingest really
ruled against the protesters will have
to be fired and replaced so basically
it's about electron in trust in
judiciary and so on so even in this
situation the parliament has passed an
important legislation and undoubtedly
all important initiatives but an todo
tuyo no tsuki are those the kind of
initiatives that are likely to convince
people in the East that it's worthwhile
to stay within the country do we need to
see something like a federalization
referendum in order to give them more
autonomy with that work I mean if you
listen to the the leaders in Western
Europe and the US I think they have been
calling on the government in Kiev to
reach out more to the provinces in the
East to actually travel there to to you
know try to try to try to show that they
care about the whole country so I think
some of those measures and actually you
know showing kind of good faith efforts
to unite the country will be important
the the debate over federalization is
obviously to what extent does that give
does that still allow ukraine to act as
one country to have national sovereignty
Western criticism of that plan has been
that federalization would be sort of a
way a veiled effort for the Kremlin to
gain control over what's happening in
East Ukraine so that that that's the
kind of stuff that's going to sleep talk
about the centralization rather if you
look historically Federation's where
construct it out of independent states
so fertilization is the process of
integration for independent entities
into one state you cannot federalize a
unitary state so you should talk about
this in transition
yawn of some of the authorities in Kiev
say federalization is simply a
subterfuge by Moscow to try to gain
indirect control and would only create
more corruption in all of the new
federal entities that would be created
is there something to that argument well
I think just so there is already enough
corruption in Ukraine and in in Kiev as
it is I well Irina obviously did some
research into the Ukrainian record of
oligarchs and corruption so certainly we
have we have here a bigger authority on
this particular issue but as I see it
there is no solution to the problem
without popular vote in the eastern
parts of the country certainly the
people who live in Donetsk and Harkov
will not believe just upon a kind word
to the Kiev government that everything
is going to be fine after May
twenty-fifth and they will get autonomy
as you say and that the the whole
structure will be decentralized they
want to have hard facts on their hand
before it happens because they learn
from them from the previous from from
from the recent past how that opposition
which is now forming the government just
dismisses any contracts any treaties any
agreements signed the night before and
just proceeds creating facts let me
briefly get a last answer from arena
Solan echo if a referendum were to be
held how would such a vote come out one
social sciences institute in Donetsk
said only fifteen percent of the people
that they pulled what to see a federal
structure exactly so that's a good
question but there might be a lot of
speculation and it's a speculation
switch already populistic of course
people want to have more tone anymore
powers but it depends how you frame
questions what kind of awareness raising
you do at the moment I don't see
preconditions and people really want to
enter a state from what i know is no
thank you very much to all of you for
being with us today and thanks to all of
you out there for tuning in we'll be
bringing you more coverage of the
situation in Ukraine stay with DW for
that bye bye